hi everyone I'm really excited to be
here and share some of our recent
research with you my name is feifei Lee
I'm a sequoia professor of computer
science at Stanford University and also
co-director of Stanford Institute of
human-centered AI Stanford High okay so
the topic of our conversation today is
from seeing to doing understanding and
interacting with the real world
I want to take you back
540 million years ago and what is it
life like at that point animals lived in
the primordial soup of a young younger
Earth and most importantly there aren't
that many animal species the world is
relatively simple uh you're seeing that
artistic rendering of this and this is
something remarkable happened in
geologically a very short period of time
and that's what zoologists evolutionary
biologists would call the Cambrian
explosion during about 10 million years
which is very short amount of time the
number of animal species just exploded
suddenly the very laid back environment
in the primordial soup of the earth
becomes a lot busier there are so many
animals in different eye shape and form
and doing busy things so what happened
the main theories between climate change
chemical change in the water and other
theories but one of the leading theories
is very intriguing and it was proposed
by Andrew Parker a relatively young
zoologist from Australia he conjectured
that the Cambrian explosion is triggered
by the sudden evolution of vision
which set of an evolutionary arms race
where animals either evolved or died in
other words perceptual ability to see
and sense the world was the beginning of
a very long Arc of evolution and of
course 500 mil 40 million years later
most of the animals in the animal world
uses Vision as one of its primary
sensing apparatus and and also visual
intelligence is defining to animal lives
and humans are no different we use
Vision to survive to navigate to
manipulate things to interact with each
other to understand the world
um it's the the you know it is said that
50 percent of our neocortex is involved
in visual processing understanding
visual intelligence is key to
understanding intelligence
so of course I've been fascinated by
vision and I do believe vision is a
Cornerstone of intelligence and what we
use this Cornerstone for both as many
animals but also especially for human is
to understand the world and to do things
in the world and that that is the two
topics I want to talk about today
using Vision to understand and using
Vision to interact I'll begin with a
series of seminal stud studies in recent
decades
that underscores the powerful nature of
human Vision intelligence one study is
by our bitterman he showed two types of
pictures one on the left he calls the
congruent picture where the human
subjects are asked to detect an object
in this picture in this case it's a
bicycle you can see it on the lower left
corner the amount of time they have is
150 million seconds in the meantime in
randomized Trials the human subjects are
also asked to detect the bicycle the
same bicycle in an incongruent picture
and you can see they're scrambled but
intriguingly the bicycle itself or the
physical
location of the pixels of bicycles on
the screen is in the same position yet
the performance reaction time and
performance of human subjects for the
incongruent picture of bicycles
was longer and less accurate so it
underscores a very intriguing capability
of human intelligence that sees rapidly
a holistic scene before it sees adding
single objects and similar in similar
vein in a series of studies called rapid
cereal visual perception RSVP Molly
Potter and other colleagues have found
out that humans can detect objects that
they've never seen in very rapid and
accurate ways in this case the refresh
rate of this video is 10 Hertz so every
frame is only presented for 100
milliseconds yet if your task as an
audience is to detect a human somewhere
in this video you have no problem seeing
that frame containing a human even
though you have never seen this video
you don't know what I mean by human in
terms of its shape clothes you know
gesture location yeah you have no
problem doing that and fast forward
um in you know almost the turn of the
century a bunch of
neurophysiologists have found and put a
Time on the speed of visual processing
they used to bring EEG studies to
measure uh exactly how fast can humans
categorize complex objects such that
such as animals versus no animals and
the use of photo data set you can see
there there are these are examples of
hundreds of pictures of animals and
hundreds of pictures of distractor
images they're very complex yet by
measuring the brain waves of humans we
the the experimenters find out that at
150 milliseconds after the onset of the
signal there is a differential brain
signal that shows the categorical
difference between a person seeing
animals versus a person not seeing
animals again this is underscoring how
rapid and robust our visual capabilities
are last but not the least I want to
share with you a study I did at the end
of my PhD which is almost 15 years ago
where um we asked people to look at real
life photos for very short amount of
time and then we quickly mask it with a
wallpaper looking mask and then to type
what they see if the presentation time
is 500 milliseconds for the picture it's
like eternity people can write novels
depending on how much you pay them but
there's a lot of comprehension seeing
the the objects the things the the
activities the mood the the layout and
all that but even as short as let's say
67 milliseconds or 100 milliseconds
these are like literally a blink of an
eye human subjects are able to
recognize objects and things
so seeing is understanding the ability
to see the world and not only to just
register the grayscale values or the the
reflectance or the colors of the pixels
but to making sense of the contents is
really critical for humans and we want
to enable computers to do that and what
is a critical understanding task if we
go back to this experiment we just
shared you recognize that humans
recognize objects calling out and
labeling objects in a visual scene is
critical to the ability to understand
the full full picture so object
recognition is a fundamental ability for
humans and of course for computers that
we would like to make them have and for
those of you who are not familiar with
this term uh genetic genetic way of
defining object recognition is giving
the computer a picture and hoping the
algorithm can label the picture with its
main objects
it's very effortless for humans apart
from the fact that you might be
wondering what this cute little animal
is we recognize daily objects very
easily but if you think about it it's
actually not that easy objects come into
all kinds of shape and forms lighting
articulation occlusion clutter and all
that so it's really mathematically
there's infinite ways of rendering a
single object let alone a class of
object in the 3D World so this is a
daunting task now what have computer
scientists done in the history of trying
to tackle this problem in the early days
concurrent with these early pioneering
psychology studies we've got computer
scientists who are thinking about
designing models the early days of
models are hand designed they tend to be
configurations of geometric shapes such
as geons or what we call generalized
cylinders and so on
that didn't get us very far other than
its great conceptual work so then
around the turn of the century the
problem of object recognition turned
from hand design models to hand design
features but learned models through
statistical machine learning so these
are just examples of how the field of
computer vision uses hand designed
features like patches and textured
patches of images and try to learn
statistical models by automatically
estimating the parameters that configure
these patches and there has been some
early success and uh one thing that has
impacted the field quite a bit is the
the recognition and introduction of data
sets and benchmarks and for example
Pascal VOC or Caltech 101 these are
seminar data sets that test machines
ability to recognize a handful of object
categories
so that was around the time I become a
professor in 2005 2006 and was really
fascinated by this problem and was
working on various kinds of machine
learning models but one thing that
really bugged me was that
um the whole field was testing on a
handful or a few dozen object classes
whereas the real world truly has way
more objects that that just a few dozens
in fact I was very inspired by a
psychologist called JJ Gibson who um
really advocated an ecological approach
to perception and someone summarizing JJ
Gibson's uh position is that ask now
what's inside your head but what your
head is inside off it's really a way to
accentuate that when you think about
representation and intelligence not only
you want to think about the the core
task we're doing here which is visual
understanding but really what
environment we're doing it in and and
for what purpose and here our goal is
not to recognize 20 objects our goal is
to recognize and understand the full
world the the full scale of the world so
long story short we went from these
traditionally smaller scale data sets to
our project imagenet which we assemble
15 million images across 22 000
categories and really try to start
pushing the field towards that kind of
large-scale object recognition through
image that challenge and of course
everybody knows in 2012 Jeff Hinton and
his students published the paper uh
image that classification and enter
image challenge using convolution on
your network and that was the year that
this winning model showed tremendous
progress in cutting the errors down of
object recognition algorithms and since
then the fuel's progress has just been
enormous in object recognition itself
we've been seeing winning
algorithms of image that Challenger
related tasks
every year are producing incredible
results and not only algorithms have
been have been advancing also you know
the the the the kind of the size of the
um of the work of the of the algorithms
and the efficiency of the algorithms
also have been advancing so it's really
uh very exciting so since
2012. but of course when it comes to
visual processing visual understanding
and perception there's a lot more Beyond
object labeling for example if there are
two pictures both labeled as lava and a
person it feels like they must be
delivering the same story in fact
they're very different pictures one is a
llama standing next to a person the
other one is chasing a person so a
psychologist Jeremy wolf once said one
could imagine
objects will be sufficient to categorize
a thing but it's not necessarily true
relationships between objects must also
be coded as part of the story of the
scene so going Beyond image that our lab
has done some work in encoding
relationships through a scene graph
representation here given this image the
pink boxes you see are labels of objects
like cake person camera a doll
earring and and all that but the green
boxes you see are relationships between
these different objects from eating to
left off to feeding to holding and then
the blue boxes or purple boxes you see
are attributes like the color of the
dress and the the mood of the person and
all this is a c graph that represents a
deeper story of the of the image and we
put together this
data set and Benchmark called visual
Genome of a hundred thousand images
millions of objects millions of
relationships millions of attributes a
million millions of descriptions and
that enabled a whole number of research
that works on relationship understanding
one of them is presented here is visual
relationship estimation using a
decomposable representation and what's
really nice about this work is that not
only you can recognize relationships
that are typically represented in a
world like person riding a horse it also
can use the composable
representation to learn using xerosha or
field shot to learn new novel
compositions like
um like in this case person riding a
horse and person wearing hat are both
known relationships and have lots of
training examples but person uh horse
wearing hat is unusual and because of
this composable representation we're
able to our algorithm is able to
recognize this using zero training
example and here's another example of an
algorithm have learned person City on a
chair and fire hydrant on a field and
then it's capable of recognizing persons
sitting on the fire hydrant with zero
training example of course
quantitatively we've shown good progress
in tackling this novel composition zero
shot learning
scenario and this this deeper richer way
of represent representing visual scene
for for deeper understanding is actually
being adopted quite widely in the field
there has been a lot of work in using
scene graphs for
um for different various tasks we've
also extended this to spatial temporal
video scene graph in in a work called
action genome over 10 000 videos and 157
activities and again using this
representation we're able to achieve
state-of-the-art action recognition as
well as fuel shot recognition we also
went a step further not only estimating
relationships but also putting all this
into a sentence into a story and to ask
algorithms to speak English to us so the
work here I'm showing is a number of
work where the input is a picture like
people writing on the carriage or a
horse and the output is either a
sentence to caption this entire thing or
dance captioning in in terms of uh you
know be able to narrate different parts
of the scene or even paragraphs
generating paragraphs and so on so
that's a number of work related to
um to this Beyond object single object
understanding of C so that was a very
quick overview of what we've done uh
what I've shown you
um in terms of a visual understanding
what we see here is a number of work
that capture different important parts
of uh
convert Vision research one is of course
representation for example using scene
graph is a powerful representation for
seeing understanding but uh also work in
algorithm in machine learning deep
learning algorithms and also
relationship with language but also the
importance of data and benchmarks
whether we're looking at image that or a
visual genome and at the core our hope
is to create agents or or computers that
can perceive what the real world is so
our lab has done a lot more work than
what I have shown you in in this space
but I'm gonna actually pivot a little
bit now
traditionally a lot of computer vision
work is actually understanding and
perceptual tasks like object recognition
but
but the real world is a lot more complex
than that and
what vision is created by nature is also
more than just understanding this brings
me to a philosophical argument of
Plato's allegory of the cave he was
pointing out the limitation of our
visual our visual uh you know our our
visual ability he's saying that really
the world is 3D and we're seeing the
projection of the world through our
retina two-day protection a to 2D
projection on our retina and it's almost
like we're prisoners in the allegory of
the cave where were forced to look into
a wall in front of us and there is a
full play happening in the back of her
head and being projected onto the wall
and the prisoners are forced to
interpret what the the play is
by looking at the projection of the
world so that is a pretty contrived
description of what vision is and in
fact are animals visual animals are not
tied to a chair and we're not passively
watching the the world even though there
is a 2d projection we're actually
participating in the in the world uh so
so there's more to Vision in fact if
we're only passively
viewing the world there might be a lot
of cases of Errors for example a simple
example of a monk if you're just
watching the mug
um if you watched it perceived it in a
wrong way or in a way that is say h a or
HB uh views of this bug
and it might not be able to enable you
to ever interact with this bug in in the
right way so there is a lot more going
on in the relationship between
perception and the organisms behavior in
fact real visual experience is is
extremely active and dynamic in the
animal world so here's a quote from one
of my favorite book the other Minds is
that the original and fundamental
function of the nervous system is to
link perception with action and so
perception is not passive and the
purpose of perception might not just be
to understand and label things but to
act in this world and many of you know
this particular experiment it's a little
bit a cruel experiment coming from the
60s and the idea is to show that two
newborn kittens they are put in a visual
World identical visual world because
they're yolked together but one kitten
the active kitten is allowed to drive
this yolk and move its body whereas the
passive kitten was only being driven by
the active kitten and it has no leg
movements and very limited range of neck
movements and lo and behold after a few
weeks the active kitten developed a
a intact and a normal perception system
whereas the passive kitten had a very
damaged or very limited perceptual
system and the good news is after a
while if the passive kitten is
experiencing the real world in a normal
way it regains that ability also we
found neurons in our brain called
minoleum brain come mirror neurons that
fires not just by looking at things but
by looking at actions
um and and and it's reacting to that
perceptual uh link with activities
itself so this is a long way of saying
that if you look at Evolution the onset
of vision is the onset of active animal
life it's also the onset of a long
trajectory of more and more powerful
brains so clearly there is a need to
connect perception with action and
that's what I'm excited about these days
is to look at
Computer Learning Systems or or can they
say embodied embodied intelligent
systems that have the ability to do
things interact with the world through
sophisticated person perception and
understanding of the world so seeing is
for doing in the real world
so now we want to ask what kind of doing
naturally we gravitate toward Robotics
and embodied AI there has been a lot of
success in Industry structure
environment robots but really the the
Breakthrough that's down the road must
be in unstructured environments
so in the recent years our lab has been
doing all kinds of work in robotic
learning from
explorative learning to exploitative
learning to you know focusing on
different
um and different tasks and I also want
to highlight there is a
key missing piece that we think that is
lacking in a lot of robotic research and
I want to share with you our latest work
up but let me just quickly also show a
couple of work in both explorative
learning or exploitative learning
explorative learning is what we really
call a colloquially curiosity driven
learning or learning to play and the
idea is how we can train a dynamic World
model in a self-supervised way to enable
a a learning system to form a a world
model and a self model to to learn to
perceive the world and this is what
maybe human children have done in their
infant years is to explore without a
task in mind and form that
representation of the world of course
there are different flavors of this
approach there are novelty based
approach there is a goal-based approach
and World model based approach and ours
is more a world model based approach and
were especially inspired by work like
forward Dynamics and inverse Dynamics
and so on and uh quickly we we this
particular work I did in collaboration
with diamonds and Nick Haber and Damian
maroka we we created a a an algorithm
where the goal of the world model
network is to predict the consequences
of actions and the goal of the self
model network is to predict the era of
the world model and then the actions
every step of the way is is the action
choices is by the self model
um you know that is adversarial to World
model so it's kind of a curious
intrinsic motivation that's driving the
action choices and what we get is a
emergence of structure Behavior here in
this case this this blue curve is is
showing you that
um that uh
in the early uh early uh epochs of
learning uh the algorithm is still just
learning its own ego motion and then it
starts to pay attention to objects and
then it starts to learn about one object
and two objects and so on and uh in the
uh a recognition task uh the the
Curiosity driven algorithm performs
better than random policies so that's
one line of work of course there's more
work in task driven or what we call
exploitative
learning robotic learning and most of
this learning today are based on skill
level tasks and short Horizon tasks and
our goal is definitely pushed for longer
Horizon tasks for example in
experimental setting this particular
task called to organize a desktop by
putting together these forks and these
uh rules is what we consider a longer
Horizon task in this particular work in
collaboration with Silvio savarese
you could draw an animation dark we we
propose newer task programming to
modularize the the learning uh the
complex composable learning of different
short-term skills so that the algorithm
can piece together the learning of a
long Horizon tasks and the key idea here
is a divide and conquer algorithm to
enforce modularity and and to ask our
algorithm to learn to specialize through
divide and conquer in different uh sure
sure Horizon skills and to be able to
handle long long Horizon tasks and I'm
not going to get into the details but
neurotask programming uh shows a
superior performance compared to state
of the art at that time and were able to
do long-term tasks like these um kind of
more complex object sorting tasks and in
this case the goal of the robot is to
stack a color block but um but it's
robust enough to deal with an
adversarial attack in the middle of this
experiment and learn to reassess the
state and complete the task
um another example towards more complex
and low Horizon task is to actually do
some kind of curriculum learning and
learn to generate tasks from simple to
complex along the way and this is work
with severe severeze and Quan Fung and
and you could do and the idea is that
through these generated tasks we can
learn policies that can handle more and
more complex tasks and our idea our
challenge here is robotics tasks like
this have sparse rewards and we have a
very large State action space that we
have to search through the good news is
that generative model has been
you know one of the most exciting
progress areas in Ai and machine
learning and we see generative models in
images in shapes in languages and uh
here we ask the question can we have
generative models in uh in tasks and
schematically we parameterize our test
space if this is our Target task we're
able to generate different tasks along
the way to
um with the goal of learning more and
more complex policy towards the eventual
Target task I'm not going to get into
the details of how we parametrized the
task space
in different in different dimensions we
created this algorithm where we have a
task generator that
um you know
first learns a procedural generation and
generates this task and then we have a
discriminator network compares the
target task with the generated task and
score a similarity score and also uh
assess how the algorithm does in the
current generated task and both
information gets sent back to the tax
generator the goal is that we want to
increase the similarity of the generated
task in the Target task but also ensure
that there is enough of a performance
achievement the reward is the the reward
parameter is relatively High because you
don't want to generate a task that's too
hard too early so we do this iteratively
and again we call this work option
adaptive procedural task generation for
hard exploration problems and this was a
publication last year I'm not going to
get into the the the details of this of
this work but here is for example we
tested a manipulation task
you see here the target task and the
generation and the generator task the
the the the blue Target Zone you can see
it was very large at the beginning so
it's easier to learn and they start to
shrink and also the environment gets
more and more complex we tested this in
three different tasks from push the
target objects across the bridge to
insert the target object into the slot
to clear the path in order to reach the
goal and we see a advantage of our work
over other state-of-the-art work and
okay so
um but just very quickly give you a
little bit of a flavor of some of the
robotic learning tasks we have been
doing in our lab from Curiosity driven
learning to task driven learning and
also emphasizing on learning
representations such as task graphs but
I did allude to give you a teaser that
there's some key ingredients missing in
our opinion because we already alluded
to that most of today's robotic research
is skill level tasks a short Horizon
goals and
um uh there is
on top of that it's on artificially
simple in artificially simple
environment even our own lab when we're
thinking about the so-called long
Horizon tasks as you could see it's
relatively simulated and contrived so
most of the work is small scale and
anecdotal tasks are picked by
experimenters there's no particular
profound reason that we have to be
stacking color blocks or moving one
object across our artificial bridge to
another object
it lacks standard metrics and it's very
individual lab driven so with these
constraints you you got some real world
systems like this a robot that's trying
to put a box on the Shelf it's you know
no it's notoriously hard because the
environment is real and cluttered and
that means the dream of achieving human
capable robots is really quite distant
so having said all this where how should
we close the gap clearly we have many
directions to go including developing
better algorithms and all that but we
also want to learn a page from machine
learning from computer vision and
natural language processing that
important
realistic data sets and benchmarks have
been driven critical progress in these
fields so can we
borrow a page or two from this uh from
these uh Fields so here's a revised
quote by JJ Gibson by us is can we
consider ecological approach not only to
perception but to robotic learning so
ask not what's inside your head but what
your head and body are inside of so the
point is
how do we create robotic learning
environment that mimics the real world
as much as possible
so one of the best
environments I think that the real world
robots will eventually be in and that's
really complex is household environments
household environments are ecologically
complex are Dynamic and uncertain have
large viabilities interactive and social
and inherently multitask and inspired by
this we are rolling out a benchmark
called Behavior Benchmark for everyday
household activities in Virtual
interactive ecological environments here
I'm showing you a simulation of what
Behavior environments look like this
robot is being the tour guide showing us
the the the rendered
rendered environment of behavior and
I'll give you a little more details
behavior is a
is put together by a large team of of
Stanford researchers and students with
the specific goal of creating a robotic
learning simulation environment and
Benchmark that's large-scale and diverse
that's ecological that's complex the
tasks are complex like long Horizon and
multi-steps and have a standardized and
flexible evaluation metrics so by large
scale and diverse we include a thousand
activity or tasks and we'll show you how
to choose these a thousand activities
now we have scanned 50 large-scale
real-world things and build the digitize
the 3D environment
over these 50 things eight scene types
more than a thousand uh now is actually
probably more than
um you know 2 000 object categories 3
000 object models and a large number of
objects per uh activity and of course
because it's simulation has infinite
number of texture lighting configuration
instantiations and we really try very
hard to achieve the goals of
photorealistic it has kinematic and
dynamic extended States it has flexible
materials deformable bodies realistic
fluids thermal effects realistic action
executions and object distributions
so um I've already given you an overview
of what behavior is but just to diving a
little deeper one would ask where did
you come up with a thousand tasks that's
very different from today's uh you know
handful of robotic tasks well we're
actually keenly aware of the concern
that that human jobs are at risk when AI
is more advanced but this concern is
also juxtapositioned with the real human
needs of taking care of this the elderly
taking care of the young taking care of
the sick and we have a global shortage
of Labor so between the concern for
human jobs and the concern of taking
care of our uh our uh our ourselves
better we took the approach
human-centered approach of taking all
the potential tasks that people do
through surveys like American Bureau of
Labor Statistics eurostats and so on and
I curated thousands of everyday
activities as candidates and then did a
user study to ask how much would you as
a person benefit if a robot did this for
you this is intrinsically getting at the
question of what are the tasks that
humans will like robots help and we
learned something very interesting right
cleaning is by far one of the most
important tasks that humans want help
whether it's cleaning after a while
partying and cleaning a toilet and
cleaning walls and so on but there are
also tasks that humans don't want robots
to do such as plain squash or opening
Christmas gifts so we ranked all these
2000 tasks and took the top 1000 that
humans prefer more robotic or machine
help
and we use that to formulate the base of
our a thousand activities the the 1K
activities
now that we have established these
activities we need a user-friendly
language to describe what is the initial
state of each task and what you want the
robot to achieve and this is what we
call the bddl
language where it's a logical form
of of descriptions of the of what the
initial State and the goal state of each
of the tasks would look like and to
build this bddl database for each of
these tasks we actually use both human
annotation help as well as gpt3 and we
combine the strength of all these to put
together the the uh bddl annotation
so now that we have the tasks we have
the logical form to describe the tasks
we need an environment
we need to specify the kind of
environments and and features of this uh
of this uh data set or Benchmark and we
care a lot about the diversity of
objects so we already talked about we
have thousands of object models and some
of them have properties like cookable
sliceable freezable burnable deformable
and so on and many objects are
articulated with the moving opening and
and closing and and different kind of
articulations with joints and and axes
and so on we also have environments
ranging from houses hotels grocery
stores restaurants schools Gardens Halls
to offices
add
with all these prepare we need to build
an environment to simulate all these
tasks to allow embodied AI agencies
agents to perform these tasks in this
environment and this is uh
um this is what uh we are set out to do
simulation is really important they are
fast for training they are safe and they
you can
there can be easier ways to overcome
real-world biases and can be
reproducible for Benchmark and there has
been a lot of wonderful assimilation
environments built in robotic learning
we're just showing a few here from
Habitat to AI to Thor to 3D World to
Sapien and so on and they both come with
its own strength but what we really want
to focus on is not only the ability to
interact with the objects but some of
the key abilities like the changes of
temperature wetness deformability and so
on so this is just say I figure to show
that our our Behavior simulator has
covers some of the key abilities in in
in this simulated world and we are we
have officially
combined our effort with nvidia's
Omniverse so create an environment we
call Omni Gibson because it came from
our previous work I Gibson and Omni
Gibson is this uh realistic simulation
environment where we can simulate
thermal effects transition
transition machines lights and
Reflections fluids deform mobility and
transparency and
we actually did a user study on the
realism photorealism in the rendering of
these different assimilation environment
and here the perceptual the user score
the higher the score the more realistic
it is so the users give us a pretty high
score for only Gibson compared to other
simulated environments and I've already
shown you uh one video here's another
video of what Omni Gibson can render
with a lot of High Fidelity details high
resolution and and realism
so last but not the least we can start
to evaluate embody AI algorithms using
Behavior 1K data set there is a long way
to go there's no algorithm today that
can perform a thousand tasks and we
actually just selected very few and as
selected a couple of state of the art at
that time papers to to evaluate to get a
baseline understanding of how today's
algorithms do in Behavior Benchmark one
is the soft actor critic uh deep
reinforcement learning paper the other
one is the PPO paper and we first asked
to evaluate the skill levels such as
grasping or soaking towel or cleaning
stained shelf or cooking meat or slicing
fruits and the bottom line is that
um
um
if we
provide a simplified magic action at the
end our algorithm the the state of the
art algorithm can do relatively okay
with these short skill tasks which are
the blue light but as soon as you allow
you do not allow that simplified and
active action
um suddenly it drops to the orange line
and if you increase the object posts and
object appearance diversity the
algorithm performance also drops sharply
and and
of course
just start this
oh
ah let me try it and I'm probably just
gonna
um
of course uh
um
it's not only it's not enough
uh oh here is a example of uh RL
algorithm uh trying to decorate a store
and uh um
you know the this is uh uh this is where
we're we're trying to show uh the kind
of long Horizon tasks that behavior
aspires to do instead of just these
short uh short skill level uh tasks such
as grasping or slicing and again
um using a task uh like like the score
store decoration or collecting trash or
clean table
um we have to
give a lot of assumptions for the
algorithm to perform reasonably
assumptions of you know uh privileged
access to the action Primitives and the
state of the objects if we relax all
these assumptions the algorithm performs
very badly pretty much Zero Performance
and this is kind of exciting because it
shows these tasks are extremely complex
and there is a long way to go in
achieving these tasks and uh
last but not the least we are also
considering some to real world transfer
so we have built an apartment in the
basement of our department and uh and
put our real robot into this apartment
but also created a digital twin of this
uh uh environment in in Behavior
simulation environment so that we can
experiment on Sim to real
um seem to real uh algorithms and so on
so let me just skip so this is really
the the all I want to say of behavior
you can check out the the more of this
work at
behavior.stephyr.edu we're just very
excited to create this environment and
Benchmark that really aims to take
robots into the real world environment
um and uh and challenge ourselves in
thinking about tasks that goes Way
Beyond the simpler shorter Horizon
skills at level tasks and of course uh
um you know never mistaken a Clear
Vision for a short distance there is a
long way to go behavior is really only
Impossible by a uh a large number of uh
Pi students postdocs and the team is
still expanding
and overall this is uh uh this is what's
been exciting me is this missing piece
in robotic learning which is driven by
um
Northstar data and Benchmark
environments like Behavior
and
you know at the end of the day vision is
a Cornerstone of intelligence especially
of embodied active intelligence and our
Labs work focuses on this kind of real
world
ecological approach to both perception
and robotic learning and thank you very
much